80 en quelques images je vous propose de
revivre cette soirée qui pour tous ceux
qui y ont assisté
restera un souvenir inoubliable à
l'entrée de platini 35000 spectateurs
debout dans les stades acclament celui
qui pendant sept ans sous les couleurs
de l'as nancy lorraine a fait vibrer ce
même public de marcel picot les plus
grandes stars mondiales du football sont
là et l'applaudissent un plateau
inestimable jamais réunie en france
353 pigeon s'envole dans le crépuscule
symbolisant les 353 buts marqués par
michel platini au cours de sa carrière
magnifique plateau offert au public
lorrain cette image réunissant les trois
grandes stars du football mondial le
brésilien pelé qui entrent sur le
terrain sous des acclamations de la
foule
l'argentin maradona et le français
platini réunis symboliquement sur une
même image
pour le match et en quatre images